there he is you say kikuchi making his
25th start on the season a 4-3-3 era
on the season with 145 strikeouts the
month of august in five games has not
been kind of a 5.87 era in august most
of that damage being done in the last
three games um four starts this year
for you say against the astros this
comes back and finds them
it's a good start two pitches and one
away one out of nobody on for left
fielder oledmi diaz
the one-two pitch and a swing and a miss
for strike three so right away a
strikeout for usa first of the night and
right away two outs for the astros here
in the top of the first eddie i just
like to see that we're seeing 95 miles
an hour the booze for carlos correa two
up and two down the wind-up and the 3-2
to correa swing and a miss at a fast
fall at 97 for strike three fans diaz he
strikes out korea and then will retire
the side lance mccullars on the mound
for your houston astros making his 23rd
start 10-4 on the season pretty good
numbers against the seattle mariners two
and over that 4.50 at t-vomo park in his
career he has a 2.96 era against the
mariners
that ball hit hard past jose altuve into
right field
jp crawford on a 3-1 pitch singles into
right well here's the two-seamer running
away from him i'll be on the outer third
of the plate but he's able to barrel it
up stings it into right field lead-off
man reaching for mitch haniger
shot to center field myers makes the
catch squared it up but out number one
on the ground
altuve has it but the mariners had the
runner jp crawford in motion which
helped out as they
stayed out of a potential double play
on the 3-2 pitch seeger grounds out for
the second out so a little spot early
for lance mccullers base is loaded in
two outs
that's a ground ball right side
backhanded by yuli he underhands some of
colors who gets the first and plenty of
time and the inning is over so the
mariners load the bases run up
mcculler's pitch count but they do not
score and after one astros nothing
mariner's nothing jake myers digs in
center fielder banning eight for the
astros last night hit the go ahead rbi
and the kaguchi one-two pitch swing and
a miss he got him with another change up
for strike three and that's gonna retire
the side strikeout number three one on
one on for diaz
first pitch to diaz swing on head up the
middle here's jp gathers flips the toro
for one over the first double play
right on time six four three inning over
we go bottom three
jp kaneker and seeger top of the order
for the mariners jp crawford leads it
off
the opposite way and away from the shift
crawford is two for two
well the colors he wanted the breaking
ball on the pitch before call to strike
it was borderline bottom of the zone
this one's just a hanger in the middle
of the plate
3-2 pitch is hit hard right field
hooking but tucker's there
makes the catch in deep right field for
the third out so there we go we've got
three in the books in seattle it's the
astros nothing and the mariners nothing
usa has faced the minimum in two of the
first three innings facing carlos correa
as correa ropes one over the head of jp
crawford there is the first hit for the
astros carlos correa now eight for 17 in
his career against kikuchi spinner right
in the middle of the play 112 on the
exit v low
euley hits the ball hard again over jp
crawford's head just like carlos correa
back-to-back singles
for the right-hand hitters correa and
guriel alex walked in his lone played
appearance tonight there's one
outrunners on first and second
and right field bowers closes and he
makes the catch
another dynamite play defensively from
jake bowers in the outfield he has had a
terrific home stand that's for sure i
think bregman correa out at second base
both thought this was going to be a base
hit for sure and a nice jump out there
by bowers concentration making the catch
tried to double him off at second base
that's one out runners on the corners
lance will face jared kelnick here's the
pitch
breaking ball got him strike three on
the
curve ball once again and kellnick puts
his head down and walks back to the
dugout that's the second strikeout for
mccullars both of them on kelney so two
on and two outs mariners still looking
for that clutch base hit against lance
for colors
and he was not granted time but it
misses outside and it's ball four
and the colors it was never granted
he could have thrown it right down the
chute
and the city would be over
another long inning he threw 30 pitches
in the first facing his sixth batter
here in this fourth inning
and it's grounder to the right side easy
play for guriel waits on it scoops it
and takes it himself
for the third out of the inning so once
again the mariners strand the bases
loaded and we'll go to the fifth now
lance will go after kyle seeger here
with the bases cleared and two outs
and seeger lifts it in the air to left
diaz started back now coming in waiting
and he puts it away with both hands
above his cap and it's a one two three
inning for lance mccullers junior and
after five innings in the pacific
northwest astros nothing mariner's
nothing
a single and a strikeout
that ball sliced down the line at right
field that is a fair ball heading all
the way to the wall carlos correa
digging for two
he'll have a stand-up double with one
out here in the sixth inning so jordan
looking to do some damage against a
lefty he has hit well five for 15.
2-2 pitch
off the fist broken bat looper left
field marmo marmo comes in makes the
catch on a sliding effort
that's a big out right there to get
alvarez for out number two
here's toro he's walked and singled this
ball's lifted pretty deep by toro over
toward the line long run for diaz and he
runs it down and goes into a headlong
dive on the warning track
excellent catch by oledmi's diaz
catching up to that baseball for the
second out seemed like it was a race
between that
sly spin of the baseball and diaz that
diaz won finally caught up to it jake
myers center fielder they hit her now
with two out of nobody on
breaking ball swung off popped up
playable jp calling everybody off going
towards the second base bag it's been
bagging the grass he's there makes a
catch inning over nicely done by usa
kikuchi seven strong shutout innings
giving up just four hits we go bottom
seven
this is ripped out to left center field
for a base hit and against past celtic
marmalade right there altuve scampers to
second and he slides in
a defensive miscue
we saw a number of those last night in a
close game yep and against this club you
can't do they can't
help them out at all go ahead run it
second two outs top of the eight the
look in by seawall and now the
right-hander is 2-2 to correa a swing
and a miss at a slider for strike three
paul seawall strikes out the side here
in the top of the eighth inning and the
game is still scoreless no runs what a
month for ty france what a year for ty
france looking for a base hit to give
the mariners a lead here in the bottom
of the eighth inning graveman ready
comes in and it gets him at 98.
it's a new franchise record
set tonight by ty france the 20th time
he has been hit by a pitch this year
opportunity for toro for the two men
once traded in part for one another who
will get the best of this battle one out
bases loaded the mariners have left them
loaded twice tonight
he drills this
drilled and crushed and this is
and he wins
on this night that trade for the
mariners wonder what the five of the
clubhouse will be tonight
myers stings this to center counter
closes on it and makes the catch the
mariners shut out the astros in back of
an abraham toro
8th inning grand slam off of kendall
graveman
[Applause]